we have more
megan fox and mgk oh
i'm gonna need to eat a bagel before we
left
if you didn't hear us go off last week
rituals chakra sound bad psychedelic
hallucinations organic smoothies
you probably did hear it actually most
of the stuff that they said was actually
from this video that gq posted it's an
interview with both of them oh i love
the time stamp on this
be abducted by a ufo
mgk if you're interested we can make
that happen yeah dude we have one yeah
no he probably walked through that door
and smacked both of us yeah and
literally would at least he'd try but we
wouldn't be here to be smacked
that would be [ __ ] hilarious beam him
up he walks on a set and we're just not
there beam him up on like a monday
supposed to oh no the email just said
the guys just want you on the show
[Laughter]
so here you are go for it rolling
do whatever you want
okay let's see this what's my favorite
movie now and if you don't know this
i'm going to be very upset at you what's
my favorite movie
now
i can't wait for it to get cold and i'm
going to make it oh no no no no you
don't you don't have to you don't have
to go there it's like an eight series
piece we're talking about harry mother
potter yes don't think that i'm not
my favorite obviously prisoner of
azkaban
prisoner of azkaban yes yes did he just
teach her to do like a blood handshake
he learned from the internet
i don't know a little rocket power
handshake
hairy [ __ ] potter [ __ ]
it's just violent high five dude
oh
good joke thanks
what's your favorite movie harry
[ __ ] he had to like teach her
how to do that [ __ ] like were they just
like sitting at home he's like no you're
gonna go like this and then like that
and then it's cool i don't know i i
think like between
you know all the tantric
night
terrors or whatever violent night terror
sex yeah i think between the uh rosary
sex yeah
they're practicing handshakes maybe
riding this [ __ ] uh
he's like oh damn
killing this [ __ ] again gotta make me
[ __ ] calm
i don't know my
hidden talent
no
buddha don't you dare i don't
you dare okay high school so high school
was that not so high school buddha
what's my what's my hidden talent
babe
don't
what if it's something actually dope
like she can do magic yeah
don't she's like she can do magic
what the [ __ ]
all right pick a card
doing david blaine
no she's really good at those
sticks you know the sticks where you
juggle a third stick what's that thing
called yeah yeah oh yeah then everyone's
like oh damn that's that's [ __ ] hard
babe don't don't don't he's like you
know those weird like three sticks she's
like really good at that and she's like
hey what the [ __ ] i just told you not to
say that
all right
devil sticks oh
oh that's the maybe she is good with
double sticks wow
the mg cage in the back leg she's also
good with another devil stick yeah she's
like don't go there
buddha
only pg answer she says okay what's
what's the hidden talent pg-rated
answers okay god well one your i your iq
is if you were my jeopardy partner you
could would honestly win every single
category i've never you you are an
almanac and encyclopedia and dictionary
all-in-one almanac
pause an almanac that's a crazy
statement to make yeah my girl could
tell you the weather all the way back to
1980 as it relates to irrigation and
farming
and she's really good with devil sticks
[ __ ] crazy she's just over there in
1985 there was a crazy drought in rural
alabama because of the way the gulf of
mexico was exhibiting you related to
astrology as well
the pollution in the sky changed the way
we observed the stars and many people
didn't realize that the scorpio's okay
damn
damn that's a good job thanks bro
ow
[ __ ]
next clip please
what's my favorite way to decompress
after a long time baby babe
don't um
honestly she likes to suck me off
just really crass what's my favorite way
to decompress [ __ ] my nut
slurping off my dong
probably when i make you squirt
how do you even know what it is
okay look what the doctor said was you
are insane we cannot say that on campus
that's your favorite way for me to
decompress after a stressful day what's
my favorite way to decompress after a
stressful day that would be
tea
and a foot massage and reading a book
and watching a show together
probably crying a few tears definitely
crying for sure [ __ ]
damn
i'm picturing the crew right now they're
just filming
pure silence babe don't
don't
i think it's when you like to suck off
my big ass dick
just holy in it um maybe it's when you
gargle my big fat nuts in your mouth
she's like don't don't don't they're
like
what you're saying the camera guy's
saying yeah like the camera just like no
no no no mgk saying that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
camera crew tries to get in on it i'm
saying i'm just picturing all these like
old dudes who have had a crush on megan
fox forever you know what i'm saying
creepy man creepy no
we gotta stop it right there
let's dive it right there mgk maybe just
uh uh weed maybe just say that yeah
reference that again i am weed weed you
know yeah no i think it's when she likes
to suck my cup okay
okay we'll take five
and let's regroup we should just change
the question actually it's like so high
school like they're just sitting there
being like oh we can't tell them how we
[ __ ] cause you know we [ __ ] everyone
[ __ ] man
there's nothing that you've done that we
haven't seen on pornhub i don't know
dude like that's what we were talking
about last week if they were like what's
my favorite way to decompress and he's
like oh my god you love stabbing new
horns in the face and then you know we
like have sex in their blood what's your
favorite yeah
[Laughter]
oh wait we can't say that on camera
right we can't say that on camera oh
okay okay oh it must be when uh
we we go around driving to look for a
nine-year-old so we can break your
kneecaps this is hilarious because i
just know where you're gonna go with
this what does my perfect day off look
like
i mean there is no day off is the point
she thinks that i work all the time
when's the last time you had a day off
when we went to bora bora in january
almost a year ago
if i did have a day off what would it
look like what did we do in bora bora
that day
how long did we walk on that gravel road
an eternity because we ate mushrooms
those mushrooms were very strong
so your day off would be us wandering
around on mushrooms yes
and then what did we see at night as
soon as a system of a down song
oh that's so cool
but maybe it's endearing you know that
they're regular people yeah yeah maybe
maybe it's not like like they're not
trying to be over the top like oh we
love to go to that 17 000 restaurant
it's like no i just want to walk in
beach take mushrooms maybe that part is
endearing no but i think yeah
yeah yeah yeah true their tone feels
like they think what they do is really
cool that's what i'm saying yeah that's
exactly what i'm saying and maybe it's
like not
they're not like trying maybe it's not
true i don't know yeah but that's that's
how it seems to me is that like they
think that's really crazy and cool yeah
maybe that's you know
i'm you know i don't know why i'm
sitting here trying to be positive this
[ __ ] is goofy as [ __ ] it's just
objectively goofy yeah it's like get on
camera and be like
we have sex
and we like drugs sometimes too
and they saw ufo too
you see that's what i want to know about
what do they see this ufo might have
been ours for real i know i was there
how many albums do i have
he said he saw a ufo and she said that
she was there we don't care about your
baby stabbing sex tell us about the ufo
yeah and on one respect i feel a little
bit bad like bagging on them but then
they did this so
yeah if i was an animal what animal
would i be told
i got tricked into reading that question
no check that wait no no no check this
out check this out
[Applause]
i don't understand what's happening
what's going on remember do you remember
when do you remember did you catch that
do you remember when
do you remember when
what'd she say i don't know what what's
the joke here i let's look for the photo
machine gun kelly photo and then if you
also google any meerkat photo
and you split screen those oh i hate you
you cannot tell the difference do that
right now because it ever looked more
like an anime what animal do i does my
personality remind you of sometimes like
a bunny rabbit because you're sensitive
and like also frightened and like
fragile
and then other times like
dragon we're done i don't want to watch
this like not a single
more word out of these two we're done
the holes in my brain that i already had
are way deeper now i watch that and i
feel like my brain is dolphin meat like
just
smooth like just gorilla for it
no that's rough there's like lines in
there there's some degree of like memory
dolphins yeah just dolphin no the meat
underneath that smooth ass [ __ ] just
glistening
stupid
lobotomized this major feeding tube yeah
just watching mgk making fox interviews
meerkat